let's go to headlines so a couple weeks
ago a student at Kansas State Jaden
McNeil tweeted a joke about George Floyd
the tweet said congratulations to George
Floyd on being drug-free for an entire
month ok that was the joke edgy joke ok
it's the kind of thing that at the
absolute most a joke like that warrants
a sort of a hey man too soon or
something like that at least that's how
normal sane well-adjusted mentally
balanced adults respond to offensive
jokes whoa hey that's the most that an
offensive joke should ever get out of
you whoa like that and then you move on
with your life and you forget about it
because hopefully there are I mean quite
literally a billion other things in your
life that are more important to you than
the joke that you just heard or saw on
Twitter but we happen to live in a
country that is home to lots of people
who are not saying not well-adjusted and
not mentally balanced and this is doubly
triply quadruple e true in in our
colleges so this tweet provoked an
enormous reaction with students
panicking over it and the administration
of the school treating it well just just
look at these statements that were
frantically sent out by the
administration on the day of the tweet
the day of the tweets the day that will
live in infamy because of the tweet
this is Thomas Lane Dean of Students
this is what he said
for those impacted by this incident
please know there are supportive
resources available including the Office
of Student Life Counseling Services and
k-state diversity okay this sounds like
there was a school shooting that that's
supportive resources for those impacted
that's the kind of thing you hear after
a shooting but there was no shooting
nobody was killed nobody was injured
nothing happened to anybody nobody was
hurt in any way whatsoever there was a
tweet what would even what would it even
sound like to go and seek resources
because of a tweet I just want to know
what that that exchange when a student
goes into
Office of Student Life was like what are
they saying yes hi I uh I saw the tweet
please help please help me I saw the
tweet I saw the tweet something like
that I imagine and then here's a message
from the school president a message from
President Richard Mayer says the
insensitive comments posted by one
k-state student hurts our entire
community these divisive statements do
not represent the values of our
University we condemn racism and bigotry
in all its forms we are launching an
immediate review of the university's
options black lives matter at Kansas
State University and we will continue to
fight for social justice hurts the
community how exactly can you explain
that one pres I mean it's in specific
detail I want you to walk me through the
steps okay step one somebody tweets a
joke about George Floyd and then there
are a few more steps and then someone is
hurt like what what happens it how how
does that tweet become a thing that is
hurting someone and in what way are they
hurt by it that's what I want to
understand also by the way why is it
just assumed that this is racist it's
yeah it's it's it's a it's an attack
against an individual named George Floyd
you could say it's it's in poor taste
you could you could use all kinds of
different actions how is it
automatically racist if George Floyd was
white and the exact same joke was was
told that well then I guess it wouldn't
be racist then you would just you would
say it was in poor taste it's personally
offensive to George Floyd his family
that's what you would say you wouldn't
say it was racist so anyway that was
over a week ago and the traumatized
students still have not recovered from
this they haven't gotten over here's an
article on kansas city calm let me pull
I just have to read some of this too
the headline is I am totally scared
black students dread return to Kansas
State after racist tweets
well I we just had to pause right there
dread return after tweet it says mikela
Ross at Kansas City a Kansas State
University sophomore went our internship
boss at ExxonMobil last week and told
him I'm scared to go back to school she
wanted him to know why she couldn't
concentrate on work she was preoccupied
checking in with schoolmates after a
k-state students racially insensitive
tweets about George Floyd offended
students of color and drew support from
national white supremacist groups I'm
not scared to speak out I'm scared of
the unknown said Ross I feel like the
k-state environment is hostile and not
welcoming to black students and our
administration has not taken actionable
measures against racist incidents that
have happened there and this is not the
first one in an unscientific student
poll on Twitter 124 of the approximately
700 black students on the Manhattan
Kabat campus responded to the question
do you feel safe on campus about 80
percent said no they don't and I can't
even continue reading this I just I this
is this is mental illness okay if you
sincerely cannot concentrate on work and
you have to talk to your boss about it
and you're traumatized and you're
actually scared to go back to school
because a kid tweeted something that you
have a mental illness you have
psychological problems that are much
deeper than than any any tweet can touch
yes you do need counseling that's the
thing that's the one thing I actually
agree with this stuff from the school of
us if you need counseling yeah all all
of these students that are traumatized
they all need counseling but not because
of the tweet just how do you function as
a human being when you are that fragile
that that
tweet that someone sent could make you
could incapacitate you and on top of
that it's it's it's like it's a tweet
and 99% of the people reacting to it are
not just condemning it but are
over-the-top condemning it so it's not
even like you can say you you feel
ganged up on or everyone into the tweet
was said it's a tweet everybody is
saying is a horrible tweet it's the
worst is that not enough is that is that
not enough condemnation if a million
people react to something and all but
like three of them are condemning it is
that still you need the other three to
in order to function again as a person
it's just my god let's go to number two
here and now the great hero the great
martyr Colin Kaepernick has met the Fate
that all great martyrs meet which is a
partnership deal with Disney
here's Kaepernick saying I'm excited for
this partnership with Disney across all
of its platforms to elevate black and
brown directors creators storytellers
and producers I look forward to sharing
culturally impactful and inspiring
projects this is this is I you know I I
can never cease to be impressed and and
just be an admiration of Colin
Kaepernick and his heroism and
self-sacrifice I want you to think about
what this man did okay he gave up a job
as the mediocre second string
quarterback for a losing franchise he
gave that up and all he got in return
was multi-million dollar partnership
deals with some of the biggest
corporations on earth and widespread
media claim that's all he got that's it
we all he got was way more money Fame
admiration than he had before amazing a
true martyr I mean this is what
martyrdom is number three now an
important story from the Daily Caller
it says a German man was hospitalized
Saturday after he was dared to lick a
venomous snake
during his bachelor party in the
Australian Alps after the incident was
reported a mountain rescue operations
team and a doctor were called him the 30
year old man was taken to a nearby
hospital the local Red Cross
organisation stated the man was bit on
the tongue after fellow party goers
dared him to lick the snake you know at
least this is one vestige of toxic
masculinity that we still have and I
cherish it that that men will still do
almost anything if you just say I dare
you to do it that's that's the one thing
and I think we have to we have to hang
on to that at all costs
now a report from The Daily wire it says
actress Halle Berry apologized and
backed out of potentially playing a
transgender character in a film after
she received fierce backlash online for
considering the role as a cisgender
woman according to Harper's Bazaar Berry
told fans we Instagram live that she was
up for consideration to play a
transgender man an upcoming film until
she received a flood of criticism
scolding her for taking a role from
someone who identifies as transgender
and so she's not going to do that
anymore but but so this is a she was
supposed to play a transgender man so in
other words a female this is a female
who was going to play a female and that
is appropriation okay makes a lot of
sense and finally a report from the AAP
it says New York hospitals released more
than 6,300 recovering coronavirus
patients into nursing homes during the
height of the pandemic under a
controversial now scrapped policy
according to state officials but so we
knew this was happening we didn't know
the extent of it now they're saying 6300
infected people were sent into nursing
homes but they argued it wasn't they are
not to blame for one of the nation's
highest nursing home death tolls what
they're saying is it's the it's the
staffers who who were infected they're
blaming the staffers just just to just
summarize their rationalization the
saying it's not their fault yes they
sent infected people by mandate by order
into nursing homes into the into the
places where the most vulnerable people
are not their fault though
no they're blaming the staffers just the
hubris is almost unbelievable this video
is sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description